[Musik]
das war auf jeden fall aus dem
supermarkt da hat man die qualität nicht
gemerkt
das war richtig war das war anlass ist
nach bremen aber dass die schmecken
besser weg
so was haben wir denn hier noch 1 10
vanessa und wellen schwer nicht aber das
macht ja keinen sinn habe meine finger
zwischen geklemmt
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich gibt es gut dass wird er in
köln ist heute wirklich extrem heiß
irgendwie ist auch schon die ganze woche
heiß
ich glaube ich habe die letzten vier
videos alle so gewonnen dass ich gesagt
habe war heute ist dann auch wieder heiß
das ist ja auch irgendwie so es gibt
gefühlt jeden tag heißt also gestern war
schon extrem heiß und heute ist es
extrem extrem heiß aber das passt
eigentlich auch ganz gut zum thema ich
habe meine haare übrigens wieder ein
bisschen blondiert juden könnte mal in
die kommentare schreiben wir das findet
es geht nämlich um eis und zwar wie man
auf insider geschrieben jo alex
vergleich doch bitte mal alles aus dem
supermarkt mit 1 aus der eisdiele wir
vergleichen aber nicht einfach nur eines
sondern wir machen es auch so dass wir
versuchen blind zu erschmecken welches
eis von wo kommt und ob das klappt ich
bin mal gespannt wann eigentlich ist ja
ganz klar dass der einzige schmeckt 1000
mal besser folgen wir uns eine gute als
sie lösen und hier um die ecke ist eine
verdammt gute szene als das eis aus dem
supermarkt leicht aber auch nicht
vielleicht ist das aus dem supermarkt ja
so gut dass das war das einfach nicht
schmeckt oder als man den 1
doch was kann man denn noch weiß und
supermarkt auf den erdbeer schoko eis
und ja ansonsten
pistazie ich bin schon wieder zurück ich
habe sechs sieben oder sogar 77
schokolade stracciatella hin wäre
vanille amarena cookies und er hat mir
ja genau alles zusammen kostet ich weiß
so schnell zu eis viele die eigentlich
recht gut ist und ich hoffe ich krieg da
genau das gleiche also ich hoffe die
haben halt alle eissorten dann stehen
uns hier wieder und machen den test und
ich bin wirklich mal gespannt was
rauskommen weil ich habe diese art von
video noch nirgendwo gesehen
ich habe die kamera vergessen und sich
mit gefilmt ich habe das heißt er kaufte
für zehn euro das hier konnte ich mir
nicht entgehen lassen dann musst du
selber noch auf die hand jetzt zwei
kugeln eis so lecker aus da wir draußen
über 35 grad haben ist es wahrscheinlich
vom geschmack des lebens stellen kühlt
oder so ich bin ich mal gespannt ob man
das bei jeder ice heute schmeckt weil
das im supermarkt ist natürlich
tausendmal günstiger
russland ist eine kugel eis mattheuer
hier haben die 21 er kostet pro kugel
das heißt wir waren insgesamt 48 im
supermarkt habe ich das doppelte bezahlt
habe aber auch das 20 fache wenn nicht
sogar 30 fahrer an länge es wird auf
jeden fall höchst interessant so heute
also ich hab das jetzt hier alles
aufgebaut maries auch dabei das geht ich
hoffe jetzt auch soweit gut
ja denn haben wissen verschlafen weil du
gerade um eine schlafmaske hier die idee
habe ich ja gefehlt schon 20 mal erklärt
deswegen würde ich jetzt gar nicht
weiter darum herum lager die haben ja
einmal eis aus der eisdiele ist kannst
du ja sehen und wir haben hier normales
eis und die sorten die hier sind gibt es
auch hier das heißt ich fange es
meinetwegen an das ist ein distributoren
und du wirst mir hier von als erstes
oder hiervon als ersten löffel und dann
halt von der anderen sache
löffel und wir schauen ob ich das okay
ich bin gespannt ich gehe zwar davon aus
dass es klappen wird aber vielleicht
auch nicht immer so anna loos macht das
hier irgendwie mal was hast du das jetzt
machen wir etwas schaffen wir die dosen
aufzumachen
bist du schon bereit ja okay es ist gut
dass wir mal ein löffel ich sage dass es
zu 100 prozent aus der eisdiele weil es
mir nicht gut ja ist ob sie als jedem
stetigen sein das andere der schmeckt
nicht so gut ist dass von ja ich muss
aber auch sagen dass man das ja absolut
an der härte vom eis schmecken kann
deswegen muss das irgendwie gleich
schmelzen dass man meister und nehmen
was sie lesen können so also ich muss
sagen das war jetzt schon mal extrem
leicht zu das kann das selber
wieso das ist mehr als ich las es grad
schmelzen ok bist du bereit alles klar
doch nicht deine vermutung sage okay was
lecker lecker okay dann kommen jetzt das
zweite jetzt mal kurz die rübe
einschätzung was würde ich nicht
gekommen von wo die schweizer börse
zürich weiss nicht mal den geschmack
statt der teller
das ist absolut korrekt machen nochmal
noch mal was ist denn was der lose aus
der dose
das ist keine dose ist ja okay da nix
100 prozent richtig weil ich mache dir
noch einen okay aber wie geht diese
chance dann auch manchmal das tut leute
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ok bist du bereit
man kann mal richtig reingehen weil mein
lieblings sein müssen dass wir so immer
eine falsche höhe kompakt weltmeister
und was willst du jetzt mal so als tipp
was wird zu sagen das kommt aus der
eisdiele höchst interessant dass du das
jetzt schon haus gefunden hast
[Musik]
vorsicht ist trotzdem gleich schnell
jetzt fordert vielleicht mehr gedruckt
das tut mir wirklich richtig lage ist
und was wird jetzt sein was das zweite
das zweite ist auszurichten
aber ich sag mal so was ist ja erst
nicht gewusst das heißt dass hier muss
auch richtig gut schmecken kann es sein
dass aus der eifel ist noch cremiger
aber dass die schmeckt irgendwie besser
also ich nehme mal schnell das welcher
um kommt von dann machen wir weiter
erlebt dann haben wir ja an laut und bis
jetzt haben wir alles ganz klar raten
das heißt man kann sagen es lohnt sich
absolut für euch auch mal in die
einstige zu gehen ja okay dann geben wir
jetzt die nächste kugel ins maul
das hört sich irgendwie ziemlich brutal
wird heute sogar keiner gefunden
das ist eine dose ist ein rundes ding
was aus metall besteht oder eine größe
ist für mich einfach ein behält ja dass
jetzt ein behälter oder eine verpackung
du musst erst ein bisschen pusten einmal
ein bisschen wärmer wird obwohl man
eigentlich bei essen pustet damit es
kälter wird also ich mach das nicht ganz
so sind okay das andere
obwohl doch jedoch dass alle das ist ein
unterschied der ist das tägliche news da
liegen welten zwischen um eine war das
zweite war auf jeden fall eisdiele und
das ist tausendmal besser als das erste
oder erstes über das erst das erste sex
schlecht ist das rein zufälligerweise
von ja nein warum er ist eigentlich
schon sagen dass wir jetzt schon die
nation oder irgendwann auch eine runde
dran
und 3 das war auf jeden fall aus dem
supermarkt da hat man die qualität nicht
gemerkt naja das war richtig war das war
ekelhaft schokoladeneis aus der aus dem
supermarkt ok und das andere also dass
wir nicht das schmeckt man schon direkt
weil das hat echt sich gut geschmeckt
wahrscheinlich genauso das schmeckt
eigentlich recht genau gleich gerade
aber weil das so okay gesagt hast heißt
es wahrscheinlich dass das jetzt gerade
aus dem supermarkt und das davor ist der
eisdiele
ja das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass hier
sind mindestens ein stückchen dran da
liegt ja die vermutung nahe dass der
einstige besitzer immer und ein
schokoladeneis hatte und sich gedacht
hat dass von ihr ab heute konnten wir
noch irgendein science gebe ich den
rücken
entschuldigung ich habe mich echt nicht
unter kontrolle
bist du bereit da kann jemand spanisch
okay wir fangen an mit numero uno
[Musik]
was ist das hallo also das ist ja für
mich so eindeutig was das für ein ice
ist ja welche geschmacksrichtung ja
vanille so ich dachte okay jetzt kommt
das zweite
aktuell das ist aus der dose das zweite
ist aus der dose rate mal habe ich mir
zwei tagen immer noch mal das hier war
dass das sagst du es aber es ist nicht
aus der dose sondern aus der eisdiele
und das ist falsch
somit haben wir hiermit offiziell belegt
das war das aus dem supermarkt und
schwingt also ich würde sagen dass
ryanair leitet das will ich machen haben
ja das kann man essen dass schokolade
heißt wenn ich auch echt gut wenn man
dann so sachen möchte wie wichtig das
problem nach ja das ist ihm bei wir
haben keinen hinweis hat das vergessen
du kannst es gerst ist das glaube ich
habe mich vertan also als fazit kann man
ganz versagen schokoladen meisten
vanilleeis
hallo ich mache es im fazit
schokoladeneis oder vanilleeis außer
supermarkt das vollkommen in ordnung
wenn es dann unsere sachen geht wie am
arena
das hier ist zum beispiel am arena ist
es hat vier euro gekostet also diese
ganze packung dass so ein bisschen high
class möchte auch absolut in ordnung
erdbeereis kann ich euch auf christen
aus dem supermarkt im film cookies auch
nicht hatten wir sonst irgendwas also
ich würde sagen es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall in die eisdiele zu gehen es sei
denn man will jeden tag eis essen dann
lohnt sich das vielleicht auch aus dem
supermarkt zu kaufen ich weiß nicht aber
welcher mensch ist jeden tag außer du
richtest du jeden tag später ist der ist
ja auch ein neues leute das war's mit
dem video wir hoffen dass hat euch
gefallen schaut sehr gerne mal bei
instagram verweilen marie und alex wie
marie las dann nach oben da und schreibt
in die kommentare was ich mit erst noch
machen soll nehmen
überall werde mich immer so viel haut
reinigen von ihrer eltern und großeltern